[Music]
all right hey let's go to lynn and
raleigh what's up lynn how's it going
hey um
it's going it's good oh man oh no what's
that mean it's going huh
well it's just another tuesday in
paradise you know isn't it though hey
you're right at the um
the audience outside of wherever you are
or is there at least one person out
there i got none um i got a couple of
stuffed animals in the corner does that
count i'm looking at like a a hand
sanitizer bottle so you win
congratulations especially if you've
named them that's pretty great
so what's up
so um
my
dad
is in the beginning to middle stages of
alzheimer's oh lynn i'm sorry how long
so
um
he's been deteriorating for about i'd
say three or four years now but um
uh but we've
we've sort of known it was coming
because he had so many um
aunts and uncles on his mom's side uh
path of alzheimer's but i mean we've
kind of known for a couple of decades
um but uh it
doesn't make it any easier to watch him
deteriorate right no it's the worst i'm
so sorry
it's weird we're making it is your mom
still around
so my mom
actually one of the fortunate parts of
the story is my mom is 15 years younger
than him so she's uh very much capable
of
uh being at home and helping him along
and taking care of him and stuff like
that so
that that within itself is a blessing
so how can i help i'm so sorry wow um
so
the problem
so i i know this is common um uh my mom
whoever's living with them right gets
increasingly frustrated with
um all the changes the deterioration the
fact that uh your relatives can no
longer particularly learn new things um
and and the forgetfulness and not
knowing what day it is and stuff like
that um
my problem is more with the family
dynamics around this
um talk into the phone there
yeah there you go okay
so
i have two questions today they're sort
of related um my
i want to be able to help my mom and
help my dad
without necessarily
taking over jobs that aren't my
responsibility and where where that
concern comes from is
both
my
husband and my brother
has sort of said well look your mom's
always done
whatever the heck she wanted to do
anyway
uh you can't you can't enable her
you've gotta this is her job you can't
move in and take over you can't like
i've got i've got
i've got family that doesn't
particularly trust my mom's capacity in
this and
while at
from the get-go
um i know where they're coming from but
at the same time i've seen her grow and
change a lot and her um ability
willingness patience
take care of him
and i have to
i have to find a balance between because
i'm i'm totally the person that's like
okay it's fine i'll go over there i can
handle it um
uh you know i'll take care of this i'll
take care of that i'm not gonna follow
through
um
so so let me ask you this loon
what is
what is not getting taken care of that
you need to go solve
give me some give me some specifics
my mom
will my mom has
uh not mom
take mom out of it because when we when
we start answering with well mom
um it ends up getting filtered through
20 or 30 or 40 years of mom oh yeah i
know
and that and that's where this comes
from so put her over to the side what
are the tasks
that aren't getting done that you feel
like i might need to go over there and
people are pressuring you not to some
people are pressing you to do it what
are the things out there that are
floating around that you need to go
solve that you think you need to go
solve be specific
um i promise this would be putting it on
my mom so bear with me for sure okay
um we'll go on weekend trips
um
dad has to stay at home and take care of
pets
dad is not good at being
that
does no longer is good at being home
alone she will not change she will not
change that portion of her lifestyle um
and
and
that that's where the frustration for my
family members comes from
well she's gonna keep going off on these
weekend trips
that's not gonna change when is she
gonna figure out that
um when is she gonna figure out that she
can't
do that anymore and so my my
i get
i'm the sibling that's closest to them i
live maybe 20 minutes away um and
and it's easy for me to say well yeah
i'll check in on that right or
yeah i'll spend the week with them or
yeah because that doesn't affect my
commute to work particularly or anything
like that sure um and and that's where
the conflict comes in is well this is
her responsibility she needs to figure
out that you know things are changing
and she just can't go wherever she wants
that any other have you have you sat
down and talked to her just yelled too
gone to have lunch together and said hey
the whole family a couple years a year
and a half ago maybe um we all sat down
with both of them and said okay um this
is what me and my brother are willing to
do to help you guys along make sure
you're staying in communication so that
we can help with whatever's going on my
mom calls me fairly maybe a couple times
a month to just sort of go ah your dad's
frustrating me again and like i just let
her vent whatever but in terms of me and
her going out
and just sitting down and saying
you know what's the game plan no i have
not done this okay
so here's a couple of things i think
that are sound like they're they're
circling around
one
is um what are you oldest by the way
youngest middles where are you i am
youngest i'm younger okay yeah but i'm
but i'm also the executor of his estate
so dad i'll be like i'm the one that dad
trusts that's right the responsible baby
so yes yeah
um
so
it sounds like
and i may just be off my rocker here
but
it's a nightmare
loving somebody being in a relationship
with somebody who's in the early stages
of alzheimer's and in the middle stages
and at the end
because it's easy to point at the task
they can't remember anything i need to
run out of town yeah you don't even did
you eat today that kind of thing have
you bathed
that stuff is the surface level
frustration
but the deep
frustration the deep hurt there is
it's like you're hugging somebody and
they just turn to dust underneath you to
sand yeah and it's clear and her sense
of security and safety is going going
because he's always taking care of
everything exactly right so yeah so it's
easy to focus on the tasks part and what
happens when we focus on the task part
is we start trying to control stuff
yeah and also one of her coping
mechanisms has has been a certain amount
of escapism so i understand from wanting
to get away yeah
so there's escapism and then there's
reality right so right
i want
i would love to see i mean i say i want
this is for you guys i would love to see
you
take your mom out you'll have the big
family meeting which every family needs
to do
and then there's the reality 18 months
later
yeah
and hey mom
like are you you're married right
yes okay now you can speak to her in a
in this is weird
relational dynamics when this stuff
shifts
um
but
hey mom i can't imagine what it'd be
like to begin to slowly
like my husband slowly turned to smoke
in my hands
yeah how are you and not an eventy he
did he spilled dog food everywhere what
but a
a a human thing right
yeah
and
from there say
that's when you can that will be the
bridge to
you're going out of town a lot if we're
going to struggle out of town i feel
like we need to make a plan
and sometimes i can be there and
sometimes i cannot
and we've got to be realistic about what
these things look like and begin to have
human conversations not
solution-oriented problem-solving but
human
and i know i sound like i'm i'm i'm
semantics here but you hear a one is one
is relational in nature and one is
who's gonna make sure the bill gets paid
both need to happen
but i think your mom desperately needs
you to talk to her as a fellow woman as
a fellow wife and say
i cannot believe this is happening
underneath you and i'm so sorry
and there's a reality here
the second part is is that i think
everybody in your family is trying to
love you the best they know how to do
and nobody's being super helpful
so
boy that's my like well and here's the
thing you as the youngest as the problem
solver and the pleaser all wrapped up
into one beautiful wonderful woman
are trying to make sure everything is
taken care of and make sure everybody is
okay with how you're taking care of it
and that's not how this is going to play
and so i'd love to see you and your
husband get away for a minute whether
that's a half a day go somewhere and i
say that all the time just clear the
deck and say yeah i know it sounds cool
to say this is my mom's job but that's
my dad
and i've got about a year left where
he's gonna even recognize me anymore and
so i'm gonna lean into that in this
season
and husband i need you to be okay with
that
yeah and that's i've i've started doing
trying to do things with him but
enjoys before he can't enjoy them
anymore um but you gotta you gotta be
you gotta be clear with your husband
about that otherwise he's gonna be angry
at your mother-in-law his mother-in-law
your mom he's gonna be angry at your dad
because he's gonna feel like y'all took
my wife from me
and that's different than you looking at
him saying i got about a year left with
my dad
and
i'm gonna miss him forever and i want to
soak up every last moment he looks at he
recognizes me and that's a different
thing for your husband
and that's him living in he'll be
frustrated
but he will
love you in a way it's a deeper
connective does that make sense
yeah it does make sense so
and be clear with your brother and
sister beca it's it's a it's a moment
where you as the executor you as the
young youngest are going to reverse
engineer this whole thing you are not
doing things to make everybody happy
anymore you're doing things to deal with
relationships to deal with reality and
that's going to be you co-creating this
with your husband and then you saying
here's what this is going to look like
and just know
this gets messy
mom may disappear
mom may completely abandon this whole
thing or she may like you said she may
turn into the most extraordinary
caregiver that nobody expected
your brother and sister who's been so
awesome and so such mentors you know
they may turn into complete idiots
because they don't know what to deal
with
your dad one of them already did exactly
they will and then but as you see that's
another phone call well they're gonna
get they're gonna get um
they're gonna get
they're gonna feel ashamed that their
younger sister's
taken over all this and so they're gonna
blame you for it they're gonna blame mom
you can't control any of that
you can control two things
your thoughts the way you love your dad
the way you decide to think about your
mom the way you decide to take about
your husband and your actions
that's it
and those actions are i'm going to be
this clear this direct i'm going to
follow this plan i'm going to have this
conversation with my mom this one with
my husband and then i'm going to tell my
brother and sister here's what we're
doing and i'm gonna soak up the moments
i can with my dad and i'm gonna not feel
guilty when i gotta go to work or deal
with my own kids
i'm going to take this control of this
thing from the head up and by the way
you're right mom's
your mom's job is to take care of her
husband that is this is her
responsibility and so you're an adjunct
to that you are not the caretaker
and when you get an impetus to control
stuff i want you to back down
and ask your body what are you trying to
solve here
is there an issue is dad not eating do i
need to go feed the dog or
am i so sad and scared that i'm losing
my dad right in front of my eyes i'm
watching him just disappear and that's
heartbreaking you gotta sit in that
grief because you can't solve that
you gotta own it you gotta sit in it you
gotta hold that old man's hand and tell
him you love him even as he slowly
the the
the recognition slowly leaves his eyes
and it's hard and that's why alzheimer's
is a
it's just evil it's the worst
that's why he's lucky to have you lynn
so lucky to have you